[Applause]
denis villeneuve has a grasp on
character-driven narratives small in
scope or larger than scope
thanks to frank herbert here's a story
that's on that scale but with characters
and relationships and stories
you know and if these were the things
that made me want to act there is no
call we do not answer there is no faith
that we betray
june is the story of the attributes
family that falls into the trap set by
the emperor who is getting more and more
jealous of their growing popularity
house of tradies stands as a beacon
where every other house in that galaxy
is in reference to that either as
enemies or as friends
he wants to not only make sure that his
people survive but that his son is the
kind of leader that he thinks he should
be paula tradies is the son of duke leto
and lady jessica and my initial
conversation denis was simply begging
him to you know be able to take part in
the film
the great houses look to us for
leadership and this threatens the
emperor gurney alec and duncan idaho did
feel like big brothers you know they rip
him especially jason he's the protector
of the traders i mean he's definitely
the head knight who watches over the
family
i mean that's his sworn duty i mean
that's what any honorable
knight soldier does now
that dad i mean that's his family that's
who he believes for
bernalick is a combat trainer and he's a
warrior oh man i fight
he's a very strict but fun visceral
paternal maternal he's all of those
things to paul
lady jessica is part of the order of the
ben and jesuit
this order that she's a part of
we can say mako perhaps the
non-traditional
partner to do gleto this group of women
who carries enormous strength and power
they are bodyguards they are fighters
they can read people
and this is what jessica is having to
deal with being a mother a lover and
this been a jesuit
how can the emperor
take
everything we built and give it to that
duke
whereas a gift not a gift
every movie needs it's a bad guys and
the darkenings are the old ancestral
enemies of the treaties the argent have
been a very dark sadistic family in this
galaxy frank herbert created a very
powerful character into baron vladimir
arkhanen he just shows up and then his
shadow looms throughout the film he's a
cause of many people's death he feeds
off fear he feeds off of pain he's a
vicious sadistic person
squeeze rapper
squeeze hard yes uncle
and the ferment
kill them all
the feminine native tribes
people living in a deep desert they have
the capacity to adapt to the toughest
environment deep heat massive sandstorm
dangerous predators all around
stilgar is the leader of the freeman he
is a powerful character his warrior but
also he's a warrior
he worries about the future
take good care of your family
dr kinds on the surface was seemingly
just somebody who's an ecologist someone
who cares about the foreign but then you
start to understand how much pressure
she is actually under
paul is dreaming about this strange
young woman
that keeps talking to him in his dreams
she feels like an old friend again and
someone that like
wants to guide him
johnny is native to
arrakis she's used to this hostility
between her people and the people that
are trying to take from her land
she's a fighter at the end of the day
house of tradies and the hearkening of
an ancient grudge and the forces that
they're up against are much greater than
he had anticipated
we're on a path of conflict and it's the
moral catalyst to paul's arc towards
something greater
[Music]
[Music]
you